[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: On the
board is one point.
In the hole is three.
All right, I'm sitting here with
two gentlemen from the Android
Studio team.
We've got Jamal and James.
Jamal, would you start by
telling us all the latest stuff
going on in Android Studio?
JAMAL EASON: Absolutely.
So I'm really excited about
a couple of new features.
First of all, as you
heard at the keynote,
we launched the
bundling in of Kotlin,
which is a brand new
language that enables
you to develop apps on Android.
The second cool feature is
around performance tools.
We launched a whole
new set of tools
around CPU performance,
memory performance,
and network performance.
So I'm really excited
about those as well.
And thirdly, we added
the Google Play Store
to the Android
emulator that allows
you to have end-to-end testing.
So you can test out things
like in-app purchasing
or the download experience
and have updated Google Play
services.
So these are the cool things
I'm looking forward to.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
And I assume you've been
talking to developers
around the festival today.
What's the reaction so far?
JAMAL EASON: Yeah,
the developers
are super excited about Kotlin.
The thing about Kotlin
is that it's been around
for about five or six years.
And a lot of developers
have been actually using it
for Android.
So they're really excited to
hear an official announcement
and endorsement from
Google about using it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, we took a
look at the profiler earlier.
And it's really exciting
to see that ability
of that level of debugging
live while the app is
running on the simulator.
What are some of the
cool things you've
been able to discover as you've
been testing that feature?
JAMAL EASON: Yeah, I think
one of the cool things
is that a lot of
developers didn't realize
is that their app is using
a lot of background data,
or a lot of active data.
So having a visualization to
see what the traffic looks like
coming in and out and
understanding what's the packet
size-- what's the latency
of those various packets--
to have a better understanding
of how to utilize network.
Because what we find is
actually turning on the radio
is actually impacting
battery life.
So having a better
performing networking stack
actually affects
better battery life.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
And James, what's
going on in your world?
JAMES LAU: Well, with
Android Studio 3.0,
we are also making
available for the first time
the tooling for Instant Apps.
So we're really
excited about that
because as you've
heard in the keynote,
Instant Apps is now GA.
And any developer can now
go build in Instant App
and publish it on Play Store.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And the tooling
that you built into Android
Studio makes it really easy
for developers to get up
and running with either a new
app or an existing app, right?
Can you tell me more about that?
JAMES LAU: Yeah, that's right.
If you have an existing
app with build tooling--
actually, we'll start by
talking about the build system.
From the ground up
in the build system,
we've introduced a new
type of module, called
Feature Module to, allow you to
share code between your Instant
App and your regular app.
So that's sort of a key
foundation piece for you
to start refactoring
your existing app
and to build your Instant App.
And then if you're building
a brand new application,
we've also modified and enhanced
the built-in templates for you
to easily include
Instant App support.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
So I'd like to ask a
general question, if I may.
Android Studio's
been out awhile,
but it hasn't been out forever.
But I think the advantages
that it gives the Android
developers are huge.
What are some of
the cool stories
you've heard since Android
Studio has been available?
JAMAL EASON: Well, Android
Studio has been out for-- well,
actually, version 3.
We announced that today.
One thing we actually
launched last year
was the lay editor and
the new constraint layout.
And a lot of developers really
loved [INAUDIBLE] XML files.
And we introduced this--
we showed the new tool.
And it took him about 15
minutes to do it the old way.
And when we showed
him the new tool
that we launched last year at
I/O, it took him five minutes.
He was amazed.
He's like, I
couldn't believe it.
So we're really looking forward
to making developers more
efficient and developing apps.
And this is some of the
things we're been doing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Have you heard any cool
stories from developers
around Android Studio?
JAMES LAU: Yeah, actually.
One of the cool things that
I've heard is in version 2.3,
I think it was, when we
introduced the APK analyzer,
we've heard stories
where developers,
when they start using
the APK analyzer,
they realize that they've
been bundling all these SO
files for different
architectures
that they really shouldn't be.
So as a result, they were
able to reduce significantly,
their APK sizes, speeding up
download speed for their users,
and just enhancing
performance in general.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
All right, guys,
is there anything
else you want to tell
developers before we get going?
JAMAL EASON: Download Android
Studio 3.0 and try it out.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Thanks, y'all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]